on va regarder ensemble cette image de
donald trump et de mélanie autres hommes
qui sont arrivés hier en forêt qu'ils
n'ont pas assisté à la cérémonie
d'investiture
alors que donald trump prend le temps de
saluer les personnes présentes
l'ancienne première dame continue sa
route tout seul à ce rythme il a quelque
peu volé la vedette à joe biden hier
lors de sa cérémonie d'investiture sur
les réseaux sociaux en tout cas bernie
sanders est partout cette photo du
sénateur démocrate seul sur une chaise
bras et jambes croisées fait l'objet
d'innombrables détournement ses
imposantes moufles lui valent d'ailleurs
le surnom de cold bernie
[Musique]
voici bernie frigorifié dans le métro au
parc sur un télésiège et où vous voulez
grâce à ce site qu il incruste dans la
ville que vous indiquez
un phénomène viral virtuel mais pas
seulement cet internaute bricoleurs en a
fait une pancarte en bois taille réelle
joe biden a tenu une réunion avec les
hauts responsables de son administration
allait regarder
ils sont tous en visio c'est assez
impressionnant joe biden leur a dit ce
qu'il attendait d'eux mais il va donc
falloir qu'on travaille tous un peu sur
la prononciation en particulier gérard
larcher l'élection de joe biden va nous
permettre d'avoir plus de certitudes
l'élection de du hobby gagner l'élection
de joe biden en même temps il ya quatre
ans et jean luc mélenchon qui avait eu
le même souci est un président des états
unis dans genre tout à fait spécial
c'est un palais de style renaissance
dessiné par un architecte italien
dix sept mille mètres carrés de surface
habitable avec des vignobles et une
patinoire dans un parc de 7000 hectares
sur les bords de la mer noire au sud de
la russie
ce palais alexeï navalni affirme qu'il a
été construit pour vladimir poutine que
l'opposant compare un tsar obsédé par
l'argent et dont il dit qu'il serait
l'un des hommes les plus riches au monde
le sujet improbable que tu maîtrises à
200% à la table de multiplication
je maîtrise à 700% un président à part
quelques questions sur la table
multiplication un show fort cette fois
8o la question piège 46 sur ces images
de synthèse des salons aux meubles
assemblé à la main par les meilleurs
artisans une salle de cinéma un casino
et des chambres à profusion avec leur
salle de bains en marbre
selon alexeï navalni il y en aurait pour
plus d'un milliard d'euros payés par des
proches du président à la tête des plus
grandes entreprises d'état la chose qui
doit absolument changer en 2021
les mythos faut arrêter ça serait venu
se dit la vérité en 2021 même si elle
n'est pas bonne à dire
par exemple ce qu'on va vraiment être
confiné ou pas la toile mais vraiment la
vérité qu'on arrête de nous dire oui
peut-être je sais pas je suis fatigué
non mais on passe pourquoi
ici à l'assemblée nationale on passe
pourquoi pour des crétins on passe pour
des crétins moi je vous le dis je suis
désolé monsieur le président mais c'est
ce qui est c'est le sentiment
majoritaire de chez les françaises et
chez les français et c'est difficile de
lui donner tort
la civilisation européenne elle est
aujourd'hui menacée de disparaître par
cette invasion migratoire non non non
non la di la société européenne et la
société le monde est aujourd'hui menacée
de disparaître parce qu'il ya un virus
qui en train d'émerger partout on sait
pas ce qui va se passer il ya des
variantes en a parlé il ya deux années
un instant avec patrick pelloux il ya
des baryons qui émergent dans tous les
pays du monde il ya une situation
économique est catastrophique dans le
monde entier nous sommes en 2021 et à
mayotte il ya des toilettes pour les
blancs et des toilettes pour les noirs
c'est ce qu'écrit une internaute dans un
tweet partager plus de vingt mille fois
qui renvoie vers un reportage de la
chaîne publique mayotte la première
l'extrait est tirée du journal télévisé
de 13h de 13 janvier consacrée aux
discriminations dans le service public
si vous voulez le problème du coc vide
il va être temporaire pendant dans le
secteur power
merci ça fait un an qu'on dit qu'il va
être temporaire on entend dans les
passes et pour sa famille c'est en moi
on a cette idée invasion migratoire qui
elle est urgente la question de
l'identité la vie à deux fois plus de
français qui naissent à l'étranger que
d'étrangers qui naissent en france elle
est où l'invasion migratoire plusieurs
sources du centre hospitalier de mayotte
assure pourtant qu'il s'agit au mieux
d'un malentendu
au pire d'une fausse information
malentendu c'est le terme employé par
une source syndicale qui raconte que
deux personnes se sont approprié les
clés des toilettes
elle expliqua désintox elle était
blanche et des personnes en face ont
estimé que c'était du racisme
le problème s'est réglé tout seul sans
intervention des syndicats et sans
mesure disciplinaire sur nos marchés
nous emmerder ces femmes
thumeries n'ont jamais te dise il a
envie de rester marocain et que tu es
fier d'être marocain reste aucun o'mara
life c'est la journée internationale des
câlins et figurez vous qu'une étude dit
que sept minutes de câlins par jour sont
nécessaires pour être heureux il suffit
de sept minutes de câlins par jour pour
être comme j'ai jolie et le premier prix
est attribué à mimi grande gagnante
d'une belle corbeille de fruits a battu
bagaté là pourquoi mini comme
célibataire n'a quoi faire et bananes
moitié chalibat r il s'appelle shoji
morimoto et il a décidé alors qu'il
était diplômé de physique à l'université
d'osaka il trouvait pas trop de métier
et s'est dit bon mais finalement je vais
m'offrir à la location matin attention à
la location en tout bien tout honneur en
tant que personne qui ne fait rien voilà
il n'y avait que d'une fesse il ya les
mollement sans s'engager totalement les
voiries buzz pardon ça dépend des fesses
avait pas d'effet c'est une grosse fait
ses plus grosses que deux petites fesses
ça n'a rien à voir ce chanteur
il a passé une annonce il a dit voilà si
vous avez peur de rentrer seul dans un
magasin je suis là si vous avez besoin
d'une personne sur le banc de touche
pour compléter une équipe je suis là sa
condition s'est fait pas grand chose un
petit bijou je ne peux j'ai pas envie de
me fatiguer trois morts shoji morimoto a
déjà plus de 3000 contrats publicitaires
ce n'est pas facile à lire
juni maître du monde pour vachon moi
j'arrête mais mais mais mais pour moi ça
veut rien dire
faut pas se mentir